silver state schools credit union the
sponsors of this next segment is all
about happy times and holiday cash back
this season i checked in with them to
learn more
scott how you doing
good rocky how are you doing
i am good i'm grateful for these happy
times so let's talk about the calendar
2022 edition
yes so i'm glad to talk to you about
this so every year silver state schools
credit union receives artwork
submissions and 13 winners are selected
to be showcased in our annual happy
times calendar and in fact this year
silver state schools credit union
received an amazing 2 000 entries which
is really awesome if you think about it
i mean that's a lot of art and so we're
you know we're really extremely grateful
to all the students who participated
into all the art teachers who supported
us in this yearly endeavor and uh our
36th annual 2022 happy times calendars
are now available and members can visit
any one of our 10 branch locations
request a complimentary copy and we also
have additional copies available for two
dollars each and if you're not a member
you can visit a branch and pick up the
calendar for that two dollars each
but again if you remember when you want
to pick up additional copies the
proceeds of it go to a great uh
uh
foundation and that's our people over
profit foundation which is known as our
plot foundation so that supports
education in all of nevada and speaking
of people over profit you guys are here
to help us save money and be smart with
our money so how are we doing that
headed into 2022 well absolutely in the
end it's a happy new year to you rocky
and me
you know and with this new year we begin
to think about new year's resolutions
obviously and so many of those
resolutions include
our members overall well-being like
starting a diet or getting a gym
membership but the the new year is also
a great time to think about your
financial well-being and at silverstee
schools credit union we offer several
savings accounts and online tools to
help you save and and learn more about
your finances
in addition our member service
representatives and our branches are
also available to help anyone talk about
their financial goals and to help them
set
be set on a path for financial success
and if you can't make it into the branch
we have people in the call centers and
any one of our member service
representatives can help out there too
but
you know we encourage everyone to set a
savings both for 2022 but also consider
establishing long-term savings goals
that will help you achieve financial
success throughout your life
for sure and speaking of a happy new
year congratulations to the silver state
schools credit union for best credit
union in 2022 via the review journal
it's an honor for silver state schools
credit union to serve our community for
over 70 years and we're thankful for our
members for voting us gold as the best
credit union for the fourth straight
year
um you know our longevity is a testament
to the great service we provide as we
prioritize people over profit
and silver state schools credit union
has been our members financial partner
and a faithful supporter of the las
vegas community and greater nevada
community
for as i mentioned almost 71 years now
and almost anyone can become a member
and part of silver state schools credit
union family so for more information i'd
also invite you to visit
silverstatecu.com
and thanks to the silver state schools
credit union for sponsoring that segment
all their information is right there on
your screen but this holiday season
remember members can earn 1.5 percent
cash back for every purchase every time
using the cash back rewards credit card
we'll be right back